il fera tous les parieurs
pas
les horaires
bravo
il boit
la guerre
c'est sûr que non
rap partout en fait un sanguin
le mirail
il dit
parce que
à voir
basta
le camp
ras il tombera en pensant qu'ils dansent
et
que tout tourne tout va non
les personnes quelque part
que
pris sur le fait
il
tous les bars
as tu des verts
droit ou le le onze niçois
il
celui de papa de quelqu'un
et
favre entrera il ira
à stargate ou aventure il
instant
il va
il ira il à stable
ah ah
le silence aucun depuis la nuit de leurs
aïeux
et puis tant que tueur tout une
environnement
c'est par là
rien que la
rendez vous
de la terre
et sa gueule de bois il vous racontera
guerre sans être sûr qu'on n'en revient
pas
pour